Je veux dire, hé, fais-tu ici, je
lui ai demandé de m'épouser, je veux
t'épouser,
euh-huh, elle y réfléchit
absolument à mille pour cent, c'est tellement mignon où as-
tu trouvé ce gars pour finir les
feuilles de calcul en plus de travailler pour  ton
père ouais mais ce n'est pas comme ça mais
ici
comment ça se passe à la maison sur la gamme
écoute je sais à quel point les choses peuvent être difficiles
là-bas très bien avec ça rien de
mal à vivre avec tes parents c'est
comme ça que la plupart du monde vit c'est juste  aussi
occidental que nous sommes tous bizarres à ce sujet,
et qu'en est-il de la gamme, je pensais que
nous pourrions vivre ici, que voulez-vous dire par
finir les feuilles de calcul et vous pouvez faire vos
bagages et sortir de la maison pendant que
vous y êtes, vous pouvez programmer  le TiVo
toi-même
non ce n'était pas pour le magnétique d'être un
chanteur pour America night
eh bien un bruit merveilleux n'est pas chéri personne n'a
jamais menti nous t'avions considéré comme un
échec il y a des années radin le
freeloader ils sont mes parents
ils ont besoin de moi non  je suis beau ne pars pas
oui s'il
te plaît où tu vas aller je t'ai décidé
peut-être la France je suis un expert dans ces
choses mais peut-être que tu devrais commencer à
Kindle un peu moins de médicaments